kunden habt dass die nazis auf die
dunkle seite des mondes geflohen sind
und von dort jetzt die welt geschicke
leiten oder dass die mächtigen dieser
welt in wahrheit echsen menschen sind
die uns alle unterjochen das sind
berühmte aber ein bisschen alberne weil
leicht zu durchschauende beispiele für
angebliche verschwörungen aber es gibt
auch jede menge beispiele die klingen
sehr viel plausibler und deswegen werden
sie halt auch von vielen menschen
geglaubt und gerade jetzt während der
korona pandemie kursieren sehr sehr
viele von diesen verschwörungs modellen
und erklärungen
da gibt es dann erklärungen wo das virus
wirklich herkommt während die
wirklichkeit dahinter steckt was damit
bezweckt werden soll manche beschuldigen
bill gates manche sehen china dahinter
oder alle steckten unter einer decke und
das problem ist dass ich das natürlich
rasen verbreitet zur zeit via social
media dass viele menschen das teilen und
das darunter auch tatsächlich
freundschaften leiden freundschaften
kaputt gehen familien sich zerstreiten
sich weil die einen glauben dass und die
anderen glauben das einfach nicht
wir wollen heute mal darüber reden und
diskutieren und uns expertise holen
warum so viele menschen zum beispiel
eine corona verschwörung glauben was
dahinter steckt und darüber spreche ich
gleich mit euch zusammen mit katharina
kuhn die ist bürgerrechtlerin
datenschutz aktivist innen war mal kurze
zeit über politische geschäftsführerin
der piraten partei und sie hat jetzt ein
buch geschrieben zusammen mit der sozial
und rechts psychologin pia lamberti eben
über verschwörungs mythen
erklärungsmodelle und was dahinter
steckt das heißt falsche fakten wenn ihr
fragen zu diesem ganzen komplex abbitte
gerne in die kommentare reinschreiben
wir gucken wenn dass ich sie im laufe
des gesprächs mit rein nehmen
katharina ist jetzt hoffentlich da in
berlin kann mich hören hallo hallo was
ist denn deine lieblings verschwörung
eigentlich hättest du dich so viel damit
beschäftigt hast ja so eine lieblings
verschwörungstheorie habe ich nicht denn
nach der recherche für unser buch ist
mir so ein bisschen das lachen vergangen
also sowas interesse begangen auch dass
man auf politischen veranstaltungen auf
menschen gestoßen ist die ganz coole
sachen gesagt haben man fand das am
anfang noch vielleicht so amüsant aber
je weiter die recherche gegen hier mehr
wie auch gesehen haben was das auch in
den familien in den freundeskreisen
bewirkt wenn jemand wirklich ganz
in den kaninchenbau solcher mythen fällt
also ich kann da nicht mehr drüber
lachen
ihr schreibt in dem begriff in dem buch
das der gängige begriff
verschwörungstheorien den doch gerade
benutzt hast eigentlich kritisch ist
warum denn eigentlich ja also welchen
grad benutzt habe dann nur weil ich sehr
müde bin weil ich den ganzen tag schon
viel unterwegs war um genau darüber zu
sprechen denn verschwörungstheorie ist
ja ein begriff wo theorie trainers
theorie ist ja in der wissenschaft etwas
mit hier sind nicht aufstelle und naja
dann könnte halt leute dann den nachweis
bringen dass ich vielleicht falsch liege
also theorie muss immer falsifiziert bar
sein und dann muss ich eben meine
theorie verwerfen und eine neu bilden
und in der wissenschaft ist das ein ganz
normaler vorgang und ja also wir haben
uns viele so verschwörungs erzählungen
angeschaut und festgestellt da ja also
beispielsweise so diese sogenannte
theorie dass die erde eine scheibe ist
da wurde er weiß ja schon längst
erbracht dass es nicht so ist das heißt
oft ist es so dass ja gegenläufige
beweise ignoriert werden da geht es oft
eher um eine glaubensfrage und deshalb
wollen wir ja diese rubrik von
erzählungen nicht künstlich aufwerten
indem wir sie theorien nennen und damit
mit wissenschaftlichen theorien quasi
auf eine stufe stellen gibt es dann
andere begriffe die man besser wählen
sollte ja also wir sprechen von
verschwörungs erzählung wenn es um
konkrete geschichte geht und um
verschwörungs mythos wenn wir eine über
kategorie von solchen erzählungen meinen
also ein beispiel wer dann etwa
klassiker wie geheime organisationen aus
jüdischen großbanken kontrollieren die
welt ja es ist gerade im rechtsextremen
raum sehr verbreitet solche erzählungen
und das wäre eine konkrete verschwörungs
erzählung und der verschwörungs mythos
also diese über kategorie wer eben der
mythos der jüdischen weltverschwörung
das heißt es ist so dass über motiv das
dann unterschiedliche einzelne
erzählungen verbindet also es gibt so
quasi einen ein überdach und dann
darunter gliedert sich das so unter in
verschiedene erklärungsmuster die ihren
erzählungen nennt
stellen wir fest dass es ziemlich viele
menschen gibt die mittlerweile daran
glauben ich habe mal ein paar beispiele
gesammelt weil gerade prominente ja doch
ziemlich munter unterwegs ist der
bekannteste wenn man auch mein rechner
schalten ist zurzeit attila hildmann
veganer starkoch hat viel geld verdienen
mit seinen wigan kochbücher und er hat
das hier mal gepostet vor kurzem auf
facebook die schlimmsten
verschwörungstheorien sind realität ich
habe jahrelang nicht sachen er glaubt
aber ich habe alle beweise dafür
die nwo das ist die neue weltordnung ist
realität und wir werden von geheimbünden
regiert und bewusst ins unglück gestürzt
als stichworte nennt er übrigens den
morgigen tag dann gibt es zum beispiel
auch die xavier naidoo ist schon in den
letzten jahren immer wieder aufgefallen
mit so theorien oder mit erklärungen
dass es deutschland eigentlich gar nicht
geben würde dass wir immer noch besetzt
sein und dann hat er vor kurzem ein
video hochgeladen
da hat er sich an der andreae chrome
verschwörung ausgelassen das ist quasi
eine erzählung nämlich jetzt ist mit
katharina die besagt dass kinder aus der
gefangenen geschlachtet werden und aus
denen wird dann eine droge gewonnen mit
denen sich die reichen und mächtigen
jung halten
das ganze wurde dann zum beispiel auch
vom fg kreis aber leipzig geteilt oder
hier sido kürzlich in einem interview
mit ali auf youtube die puma ag auf
youtube dort hat er wörtlich gesagt ich
muss kurz ablesen ich glaube schon die
großen medien sind unterwandert die
gehören alle einem reichen typen und die
sorgen dafür dass er und seinesgleichen
geschützt werden so dass mal so als
beispiel von den prominenten es gibt
aber auch natürlich ganz normale
menschen also die nicht prominent sind
die solche mieten teilen oder solche
erzählungen teilen und wir haben mal ein
paar zusammen gesammelt von den demos
vom wochenende
im moment ist die diskussion über die im
bericht von mir in zukunft bei jeder
grippewelle das land abriegeln oder
runterfahren oder was
er stützt das scheiß verschieben was sie
jetzt zur natur einzige politiker oder
korrupte
wissenschaftler 14 7 uhr nachts
einspringen dann ist auch überall wo
ganz viele kommunen waren eine 5 die
freischaltung
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ja also da haben wir jetzt jede menge
erzählungen gesammelt katharina wie
kommt es denn dass menschen die bislang
nicht durch merkwürdige äußerungen
aufgefallen sind auf einmal so etwas
behaupten ja also habe ich erst mal
sagen wenn man sich die otöne anschaut
dann kann man ja nicht bei allen sagen
das ist jetzt eine eindeutige
verschwörungs erzählung ist dass er auf
jeden fall eine verschwörung glaubt also
wenn jemand t shirt trägt gibt games
keine chance oder davon spricht dass 5g
überall da wo menschen an womit 1900
gestorben wären dann ist das schon recht
klar wenn jemand sagt sogar mit ihnen
diese diese maßnahmen zu weit dann würde
ich das noch nicht da einsortieren da
muss man wirklich im einzelfall schauen
aber der grund warum jetzt gerade so
viele menschen ja aber warum dieses
milieu so viel zulauf offensichtlich
bekommt ist einfach das
wissenschaftliche studien gemacht die
haben das mal untersucht schon ausgiebig
mehrfach also es gibt ziemlich viele
studieren das ist sehr eindeutig belegt
wenn wir das gefühl haben von
unsicherheit und kontroll verlost das
kann einerseits ausgelöst werden durch
einen privaten konflikt war
beispielsweise ja unsicherheit einen job
aber eben auch durch politische
veränderungen oder auch ja eine globale
pandemie dann haben wir angst wir haben
das gefühl wir haben keine kontrolle
über die situation und dann sind wir
eher anfällig dafür an verschwörungs
erzählungen zu glauben
sprich wir sehen muster wo keine sind
aber es ist nicht mal dazwischen frau dr
katharina wenn ich mir jemand angucke
wie sido wie xavier naidoo wie attila
hildmann die haben doch relativ viel
geld gesammelt die müssten sich doch
eigentlich keine sorgen machen
warum sehen wir dann trotzdem solche
muster und haben angst vor
kontrollverlust weil ich meinen die
haben doch eigentlich genug kapital
gesammelt dass sie genug kontrolle
behalten können naja so wirtschaftliche
unsicherheit ist ein faktor ja also
einer von vielen also wenn ich nicht
weiß
die politische situation in ein paar
monaten aussieht weil ich einfach sehr
unsicher bin über die situation dann
kann da auch großer reichtum nicht dass
du schön dass ich jetzt da irgendwie
geschützt bin genauso wie ein großer
bildungsgrad nicht automatisch dazu
schickt also davor schützt dass man
nicht auch ein verschwörungs ideologien
da irgendwo glatter verschwörungs
ideologen hinterherläuft
es ist kein faktor sind der fall zeigt
vielmehr dass prominente eben auch ganz
normale menschen sind und bei denen
wirken auch dieselben mechanismen wie
bei anderen menschen auch und beim große
veränderungen kommen dann dass es so ein
anderer absicht logischer faktor dann
haben viele menschen auch das bedürfnis
eine große ursache zu sehen also
klassiker ist ja der tod von prinzessin
diana oder von elvis da gibt es ja
unmengen von ja alternativen erklärungen
sozusagen also ja erst ein verschwörungs
erzählung wurde behauptet wird elvis
wird von medien in aliens entführt oder
erlebt noch oder princess unter jener
sie wird vom geheimdienst eigentlich
ermordet und da gibt es eben ganz viele
geschichten und das ist wirklich
systematisch zu beobachten beim
prominente sterben weil viele menschen
einfach glauben ja dass prominent der
hat doch eigentlich alles im leben wie
kann er an einem unfall sterben oder an
einer ganz normalen krankheit wie andere
normale menschen auch und genau so ist
das bei großen ereignissen wie
beispielsweise katastrophen oder
flugzeugabstürzen da gibt es eben ganz
viele menschen die intuitiv glauben da
muss es einen plan hinter geben ja das
kann kein zufall sein
und ich meine beim virus haben wir auch
in der geschichte gesehen es gab immer
wieder epidemien verursacht durch viren
die vom tier auf den menschen übertragen
worden sind ein beispiel ist die
schweinegrippe ein anderes beispiel ist
ebola oder eben ja also gibt
unterschiedliche krankheiten bei denen
das auch nachgewiesen werden konnte
und trotzdem glauben viele menschen so
nee das kommt aus dem labor und das
kommt wirklich daher kann man sagen so
ich gucke jetzt mal in die kommentare
hier sammeln sich natürlich auch schon
diverse verschwörungstheorien
den schenke ich jetzt mal nicht so die
aufmerksamkeit aber eine frage finde ich
ganz gut auf facebook von sophie singer
warum ist gerade deutschland von so
vielen corona verschwörungstheorien oder
erklärungen erzählungen betroffenen
demos gibt es ja verstärkt hier bei uns
und nur vereinzelt daran ändert ist das
ein richtiger eindruck dass wir hier ein
größeres phänomen in deutschland haben
als in anderen staaten ja also bei den
aktuellen zahlen muss man ein bisschen
vorsichtig sein weil man kann schon
sagen nur weil leute auf der straße sind
oder nicht heißt es noch nicht dass es
etwas darüber aussagt wie viele menschen
in der bevölkerung daran glauben an so
etwas oder nicht und wir wissen eben aus
studien aus der vergangenheit da wird in
unterschiedlichen ländern untersucht wie
viele menschen glauben an verschwörungen
also ganz unterschiedlich als
beispielsweise die luminaden und solche
geschichten und dann wird eben
festgestellt naja also auch in anderen
ländern beispielsweise frankreich usa
eigentlich in jedem land gibt es eben
einen nicht sehr kleinen anteil von
menschen die an verschwörungs
erzählungen glauben was aber interessant
ist dass sich so die populären
verschwörungs erzählungen auch von land
zu land unterscheiden
das hängt auch zum teil mit stereotypen
oder gar mit feindbildern auch zusammen
also es gibt länder da steht vor allem
israel im fokus es gibt andere länder da
wird er so eine arabische welt
verschwörung vermutet
bei den anderen ist vielleicht eher
amerika oder china und in einigen
ländern es beispielsweise diese
verschwörungs erzählungen dass es so
geheim orden wie illuminati gibt
unglaublich populär also in deutschland
ist es im vergleich dazu nicht so stark
verbreitet und das finde ich sehr
interessant zu sehen dass es auch so wie
es sozusagen eine eigene geschichte von
diesen milieus in den unterschiedlichen
ländern gibt und dass sich aber ja auch
die szenen gegenseitig irgendwo
die stehen schon in kontakt und tauschen
sich daraus und teilweise gibt es
mittlerweile auch so internationale
gruppen die international vernetzt sind
beispielsweise kann man sagen das ist
ein unterschied genau das ist ein forum
wo menschen gemeinsam anja mysteriösen
hinweisen eines angeblichen insiders
knobeln und versuchen das in reims
bringen also eigentlich ist er ja ich
würde eher sagen sinnfreie aussagen die
er so ein bisschen wie buchstabensalat
manchmal daherkommen und die leute
versuchen da wirklich dann muster drin
machen denn diese leute die sich treffen
und der eine sagt israel steckt dahinter
der andere sollte palästina unter dritte
sollten eigentlich ist es kindern in den
usa könnte sich irgendwann auch einigen
ja es kommt eben darauf an also wenn
beispielsweise sich alle darauf einigen
dass es insgeheim irgendwo einen
geheimen club einer angeblichen die
weltregierung bohrung gibt und die sich
irgendwie darauf einigen können ja dann
sind halt die unterschiedlichen
feindbilder da irgendwo vertreten
vielleicht können sie sich dann einigen
ich weiß nicht nur das ist immer von
fall zu fall bestimmt unterschiedlich
ich finde interessant jetzt gerade bei
den corona protesten dass man schon
sagen kann dass man sich zumindest einig
ist in den find ja dass man sagt die
medien die lügen alle die politiker die
nun alle und die wissenschaft die sagt
auch nicht die wahrheit und das heißt
wir haben auf den demos leute die sagen
es gibt das virus nicht und es gibt
leute die sagen das virus ist ein bio
waffe und eigentlich widerspricht sich
das ja schon gibt es auch tatsächlich
solche kommentare die in die richtung
gehen gerade als entgegnung auf deine
äußerungen mini suite auf facebook
schreibt was ich habe verwandte in
brasilien england und schweiz da gibt es
ebenfalls zweifel der politik also dass
das international ist und hier gibt es
dann auf facebook von ingrid 1 kommentar
weil die politik also warum verbreiten
sich die verschwörungs müssen weil die
politiker ihre aussagen wechseln die das
wetter und und stefan folgt man meint
einem stoff ein körnchen wahrheit steckt
halt in jeder verschwörungstheorie also
wir lesen ich ließ daraus jetzt mal so
eine grundskepsis gegenüber offiziellen
aussagen was ich als journalist auch
habe haben muss das ist ja meine aufgabe
das alles zu überprüfen und wenn ich mal
so in verschwörungs erklärungen oder
zählen rhein gucken dann ist da
tatsächlich immer irgendwas dran oder
das ist das ist doch auch ein problem
tatsächlich das irgendwo immer ganz
unten eine wahrheit steckt die man
finden kann
also es ist schon interessant wenn man
sich anschaut bei einigen menschen so
was der ausgangspunkt war sich mit
verschwörungs erzählungen zu
beschäftigen
dann stehen am anfang oft sehr
berechtigte fragen beispielsweise wie
transparent worden wie nachvollziehbar
ist die arbeit von geheimdiensten ja
kann ich ihnen da in dem punkt trauen
oder die sorge also ich würde halt auch
sagen wir brauchen mehr transparenz das
ist eine legitime forderung aber
zwischen der forderung wir brauchen mehr
transparenz und weiß nicht der
schlussfolgerung
alle möglichen dinge werden vom
geheimdienst kontrolliert sind halt doch
schon einige welten und das ist ebenso
dieses spannungsfeld in dem wir uns
bewegen und da für mich das aber schon
interessant zu sagen so ja am anfang
stand eben eine frage und die suche nach
einer antwort die hätte eben auch ganz
anders ausgehen können und ich
persönlich würde auch sagen wer die
regierung hat schon mich alles richtig
gemacht in dieser krise schiene
regierung haben dinge nicht richtig
gemacht ich fand es beispielsweise nicht
in ordnung wie in puncto schutz durch
masken kommuniziert wohl da hieß es
erstes brauchen wir nicht wahrscheinlich
bei einem grund kann man nur vermuten
weil man eben wusste es gibt nicht genug
nicht mal genug für das medizinische
personal am anfang und später hieß es
dann so ja der doch gut wenn ihr alle
eine tragen da dachte ich schon so mehr
dafür spielt man eben auch vertrauen
aber ich finde zwischen einer kritik an
einer einzelnen sache und direkt zu
sagen so alles was niemand sagt das ist
pauschal falsch das geht einfach zu weit
das meinen wir sind alle menschen werden
uns in jeder macht fehler
aber sie darf in einer institution macht
fehler sagst du da vielleicht auch also
eine verantwortung von politik und auch
medien dass solche fehler nicht genug
eingestanden werden dass nicht genug
transparenz da ist weil es gibt ja auch
tatsächlich dinge in der politik die
anzuprangern sind und die dann auch
vielleicht solche verschwörungs
erzählungen befeuern ich sage einfach
erstmal nur die verstrickungen von
bestimmten wirtschaftszweigen mit
bestimmten ministerien und den
dazugehörigen lobbygruppen daher
wechseln politiker mal eben von vom amt
des ministers in eine beratungsfunktion
wieder zurück das haben wir auch auf eu
ebene so was alles befördert das doch
dass menschen vertrauen verlieren und
dann tatsächlich auch irgendwo ein
größeres mustermann zu erkennen
ja also natürlich ist es nicht so dass
es keine ungerechtigkeit in der welt
gibt und keine korruption aber zwischen
einer kritik an beispielsweise drehte
lobbyismus die ja auch teile ich finde
wir brauchen viel mehr transparenz auch
in puncto parteienfinanzierung und
lobbyismus und zu sagen
die stecken alle unter einer decke ja
das sind einfach zwei paar schuhe und
das würde ich auch nicht in einen topf
werfen ich würde nicht jemanden in einen
topf werfen
er sagt mir ich könnte sie eine einzelne
maßnahme ich möchte eine
gesetzesänderung in den bereich direkt
zu sagen wie du bist jetzt ein
mit jemandem der nexen menschen glaubt
also das ist einfach nicht fair
das sind jetzt aber auch sachen die ich
finde ich hier wirklich viele den
kommentaren also es gibt relativ wenig
muss ich sagen und sachlich fundierte
fragen zu dem ganzen komplex sondern er
viele menschen die jetzt versuchen ihre
jeweilige verschwörungs erklärung hier
los zu werden also zum beispiel einfach
nur als stichwort bill gates finanziert
werden das rk ii bestätigt unsere medien
das ist etwas was viele jetzt kursierte
wo wir auch einfach mittlerweile durch
faktencheck sagen können da stimmt also
es stimmt dass bill gates die stiftung
geld gezahlt hat anders rk ii und auch
an den spiegel und die zeit aber das
waren jeweils so geringe summen dass man
nicht von einer bestechung oder von
einem kaufen sprechen kann oder die gibt
es so stichwörter wie deep stack und hat
landbrücke das heißt da gibt es ja doch
viel misstrauen gegenüber bestimmten
institutionen kann man solchen menschen
die so viel misstrauen schon gesammelt
haben das misstrauen eigentlich
überhaupt noch nehmen
ja das ist die große frage
also ich glaube viele menschen die ja
vielleicht so an ein oder zwei punkten
damit in kontakt kommen sind ja sage ich
mal nicht ganz in kaninchenbau
verschwunden dass sie so sagen ich
brauche kein medien mehr grundsätzlich
außer vielleicht drei youtube kanälen
die ich für vertrauenswürdig halten
sollen die meisten die konsumieren ja
noch unterschiedliche medien ich finde
da kann man auf der ebene noch
diskutieren also ich finde es schwierig
wenn menschen so weit ein misstrauen
haben gegen beispielsweise institutionen
wie die wissenschaft dass man nicht mal
mehr sagen kann
okay du hast deine these hier ich habe
nicht nur eine studie sollen fünf
studien die beispielsweise belegen der
klimawandel ist menschengemacht und
übrigens 99 prozent der wissenschaftler
sind auch der meinung das sind halt
mehrere 10.000 100.000 wissenschaftler
auf der ganzen welt also glaubst du
wirklich die haben sich verschworen und
wenn jemand dann immer noch sagt so dass
das und glaube ich nicht weil die
wissenschaft steckt unter einer decke
ich find an der stelle wird es schwierig
wenn man keinen gemeinsamen nenner von
wahrheit oder vertrauens ist institution
hat und ich denke schon dass zumindest
also man kann natürlich der politiker
parteien misstrauen aber zumindest an
der stelle wissenschaft sollte man noch
sagen ja das ist schon eine der
transparentesten bereiche in unserer
gesellschaft ja also
wissenschaftler muss seine studien
darlegen muss sich veröffentlichen
andere andere wissenschaftler können das
nachprüfen und widerlegen oder auch
nicht und an der stelle merkt man aber
schon das ist eben auch eine
glaubensfrage ist also eben bei
klimawandel leugner oder auch eben jetzt
in dieser situation bei menschen die
sagen es gibt das virus nicht dass wenn
ich schon erstaunlich wenn man dann
einfach auf sagt quasi die globale
medizinische und wissenschaftliche
community weltweit liegt falsch da muss
man auch überlegen was dahinter die
annahme ist also eine verschwörung das
ist einfach nicht so wirklich plausibel
macht steht auch hintergrundwissen merke
ich jetzt gerade hier im chat
die wird jetzt vorgeworfen dass ich mit
den 2,3 millionen euro an den spiegel
die die gates stiftung gezahlt hat ja
anscheinend keine ahnung hätte das wäre
wenig geld hat nicolai zum beispiel hier
vor wenn man sich aber an guckt was der
spiegel einem jahresumsatz hat das sind
nämlich ich glaube irgendwas zwischen
230 und 260 millionen euro
dann ist das gerade mal ein prozent und
von daher wenn man das dann wieder
hochrechnet auf die summe jetzt erstmals
kleiner exkurs ist es doch relativ wenig
aber das große problem ist eben dass es
schwierig ist auch zu unterscheiden
zwischen fundierter kritik und
verschwörungs erzählung das hast du ja
gerade auch schon angemerkt bei unsere
noten das changiert immer so ein
bisschen
und gerade das ist nicht schwierig zu
unterscheiden ich finde einfach wenn
jemand an dem motor sagt ich bin
unzufrieden mit der maßnahme kann man
daraus nicht ableiten dass er ein
verschwörungs ideologie ist also ich
finde das kann man schon sehr eindeutig
einordnen ich glaube da muss man sich
aber mit jemandem länger unterhalten und
da reicht vielleicht ein auto nicht und
vor allem nicht wenn er einfach nur sagt
ich bin unzufrieden da gebe ich dir
recht was ich eigentlich sagen wollte
hoch hinaus wollte ist dass das ich in
dieser kritiker bewegung gerade auf
diesen demos das ja teilweise vermischt
dastehen menschen nebeneinander die
haben fundierte kritik anderer haben
verschwörungs erklärungen und seit
kurzem gibt es die partei wieder statt
2020 wo ich das alles irgendwie zusammen
bald und wir haben uns die mal genauer
angeguckt um herauszufinden was da
eigentlich hinter steckt
der korona protest wächst und schwappt
über vom netz auf die straße immer öfter
mit dabei mitglieder der selbsternannten
mitmachpartei widerstand 20 20 grund
genug einmal genau hinzuschauen welches
ziel verfolgt widerstand 2020 ein
parteiprogramm gibt es noch nicht eine
politische zuordnung wird vermieden
doch man ist gegen die korona maßnahmen
und für freiheitsrechte anders denken
sei kein fehler sondern freiheit
soziologe mathias quendt warnt elemente
des populismus sein zu erkennen
es geht jetzt darum zusammenzuhalten
gegen die da oben in anführungszeichen
man sitzt auf schwarmintelligenz das
bedeutet man lehnt sache und fach
expertise ab man setzt darauf dass der
in anführungszeichen gesunde
menschenverstand zu einem gemeinsamen
parteiprogramm zu einer besseren politik
führt auch ein notstands parlament ist
angedacht der aktuelle bundestag soll
dadurch ersetzt werden ob das
verfassungskonform wäre fraglich doch
die partei will über alles reden wer
macht bei widerstand 2020 mit einer der
drei gründungsmitglieder und eines der
bekanntesten gesichter ist bodo
schiffmann arzt einer schwindelambulanz
via youtube meldet er sich täglich zu
wort stellt mal die arbeit von experten
in frage und setzt ein anderes die
gefahr von grip und corona virus gleich
zu einem statement war ja vorab nicht
bereit zugleich soll die partei nach
eigenen angaben schon mehr als 100.000
mitglieder haben
die anmeldungen müssen neu geprüft
werden die zahl dürfte da niedriger
ausfallen in einer facebook-gruppe sind
es wenige tausend da sind im gegnerinnen
bei da sind heilpraktiker esoteriker
dabei da sind eindeutig rechtsradikale
dabei spielen rechts alternative medien
eine sehr große rolle die verschwörungs
ideologien aus dem internet weiter
verbreiten in diese kanäle hinein es ist
also ein diffuses sammelbecken in welche
richtung geht widerstand 2020 auf der
straße sind sie noch eine kleine
bewegung doch man vernetzt sich immer
weiter und fühlt sich an der seite von
anderen kritikern wurde widerstand 2020
baut eine brückenfunktion zwischen
rechtsradikalismus verschwörungstheorien
bürgerlichen kreisen die damit bisher
nichts zu tun hatten im gegnerinnen und
bietet damit eine plattform für
wissenschafts und demokratie ferne
thesen und themen die darüber verbreitet
werden
seit gestern des widerstand 2020 nach
eigener aussage eine offizielle partei
doch ob es der protest vom netz über die
straße später auch ins parlament schafft
ist fraglich denn parteiarbeit ist mehr
als bloßer protest für den protest finde
ich auf jeden fall bei uns in den
kommentaren wieder da gibt es jetzt sehr
viel unmut über die sind live stream
über die öffentlich rechtlichen medien
im allgemeinen und das wir kommentare
löschen würden ich kann euch sagen wir
löschen wirklich nur beleidigungen
da sind wir knallhart es gibt aber auch
bei facebook jetzt da kann ich sagen ein
automatisches system das kommentare
ausgeblendet werden da haben wir dann
keinen einfluss drauf
das glaube ich ganz wichtig noch mal
hier zu betonen
katharina wände der widerstand 20 20
anguckt wie viel verschwörungs
erzählungen findest du denn da ja also
ich finde das ist gerade bei jungen
bewegung schwer zu sagen in welche
richtung die sich entwickeln aber ein
indikator kann auf jeden fall sein gibt
es eine klare abgrenzung nach rechts
gibt es eine klare abgrenzung ins
verschwörungs ideologische milieu und da
sehen wir eben einzelne akteure von
widerstand 2020
die da beispielsweise kein problem haben
bei veranstaltungen aufzutreten wo auch
wirklich verschwörungs ideologen vor ort
sprechen auf der bühne und da muss man
eben sagen so ja ich persönlich würde
einen solchen prozess nicht teilnehmen
weil ich mir durchaus also ich mache mir
durchaus sorgen darum und den zustand
der bürgerrechte langfristig bin der
mann wir müssen ganz knallhart darüber
reden wie lange die maßnahme andauern
werden was auch kriterien sind zur
lockerung und dass wir nicht langfristig
die bürgerrechte einschränken da ganz
klar aber ich würde niemals auf eine
demonstration gehen wo ich nicht ganz
klar sagen kann so wer steht eigentlich
rechts und links neben mir und was
wollen eigentlich die leute an der bühne
auf der bühne also das finde ich halt
auch interessant wie diese gruppierung
auftritt also hieß wir haben wir haben
zehntausende über 100.000 mitglieder und
dann hieß es in der presse auch sie ja
offensichtlich wurde da einfach gezählt
wie auf die seite aufgerufen ist das
finde ich persönlich nicht transparent
ich finde es auch nicht redlich und auf
der webseite hieß es man kann auch
anonym spenden
ja also das ist wie eine partei die das
machen würde
die wird sich einfach strafbar machen
also ja da gibt es ein ganz klares ganz
klare gesetzliche transparenzpflicht und
ich meine kleine junge partei hatten
also eine gruppe die eine partei werden
will die weiß dass vielleicht nicht aber
wenn wir ihm ein anliegen wirklich ernst
ist und nicht fundierte kritik ab wann
sollte ich mich gleich vorher
informieren und vor allem sollte ich
mich von milieus distanzieren die ja
nicht unbedingt demokratisch so sind und
das fehlt mir da gut das gab es in der
piratenpartei am anfang ja auch viel
durcheinander und viel unwissen dort
müssen ein bisschen gucken wie sich
widerstand 20 20 zurecht ruckelt es der
vergleich hinkt weil die piratenpartei
ist über jahre gewachsen ich möchte
sagen die diskussion nicht aus so
richtig ab weil ich habe über
verschwörungen in einer woche entstanden
nein aber wir haben es gibt die
rechtsextremen wir haben leute
ausgeschlossen
die verschwörungs ideologen waren schon
übungen wenn ich dich um verbrecher aber
ja ich war einfach in dieser partei und
klar da müssen wir jetzt einfach gucken
wie sich die partei widerstand 20 20
selber aufstellt und wie sie damit
umgeht wichtig finde ich aber die
diskussion darüber die kommt hier in
ganz vielen kommentaren wenn ihr mal auf
meinen dokument schalten weil
da haben wir erst mal gesammelt ich
komme hier nicht mehr hinterher gerade
im lesen also es gibt so was wie auf
youtube von westcoast wer ganz hilfreich
wenn man zuhört und sachlich widerlegen
kann und nicht von vornherein abstempelt
dann waren solche sachen wie wer
definiert was verschwörungstheorien sind
die regierung eine richtung vor die
medien verbreiten sie alle die kritisch
hinterfragen sind
verschwörungstheoretiker oder warum es
eigentlich jede abweichende meinung
gleich eine verschwörungstheorie darf
man nicht anderer meinung sein
also dieser begriff
verschwörungstheoretiker der wird ja
auch als kampfbegriff benutzt um jeden
der irgendwie nicht ganz die eigene
meinung teilt auch mundtot zu machen
wie kann man das denn klar voneinander
abgrenzen und wo kommt auch dieser
eindruck her vielleicht sollten den
anderen begriff irgendwann benutzen ja
so verschwörungs erzählung meint eben
eine erzählung wo es eben darum geht
dass einzelpersonen oder gruppen die
meistens so als mächtig wahrgenommen
werden einen geheimen plan verfolgen um
der bevölkerung zu schaden
und das ist erst mal so die definition
die man da verwenden kann und da muss
man eben schauen was passt da braucht
und dann sieht man sehr schnell eine
kritik an beispielsweise ein gesetz oder
so etwas erfüllt diese definition nicht
wenn man aber sagt es gibt eine geheime
gruppe die hat sich verschworen um
heimlich beispielsweise die bevölkerung
zu tippen oder was auch immer dann
erfüllt ist diese definition wichtig ist
aber an der stelle auch zu sagen dass
der begriff der verschwörungs erzählung
jetzt noch keine aussage über den
wahrheitsgehalt treffen haben und es ist
einfach eine gewisse struktur einer
erzählung das interessante ist eben dass
man diese struktur eben bei
unterschiedlichen mythen wirklich wieder
finden also dieses verschwörungs
konstrukt gibt es im bereich klimawandel
das gibt es im gesundheitsbereich dass
behauptet wird
alle pharma unternehmen würden lügen
oder würden sich mit der regierung
verschworen haben und da kann man schon
psychologisch sagen dass spielen
bestimmte effekte eine rolle
und deshalb kann man das eben auch
wissenschaftlich untersuchen warum
menschen beispielsweise in bestimmten
situationen eher dazu neigen an
verschwörungen zu glauben aber
gebrauchen wenn ich vielleicht an
trotzdem eine größere sensibilität im
umgang mit diesem begriff weil hier
kommt der focus wirklich häufig jetzt
auch noch
auf twitter von demokratie netzwerk
andersdenkende als
verschwörungstheoretiker zu
verunglimpfen ist dumm und führt den
unmut der sich den demos niederschlägt
also wird er auch nicht vielleicht
inflationär benutzt oder falsch also
gerade deshalb habe ich auch eingehakt
also bei den äußerungen dann jemand
einfach auf einer demo sagte er ich bin
hier weil ich die maßnahme nicht findet
kann man nichts keine aussage darüber
treffen ob derjenige ein verschwörungs
erzählungen glaubt oder nicht
und ich finde da muss man auch wirklich
sehr vorsichtig sein wo der begriff
angebracht ist oder nicht und ich finde
auch dass es auch durchaus ich finde es
absolut nachvollziehbar wenn menschen
kritik an den maßnahmen üben trotz allem
finde ich auch muss man darüber sprechen
wenn diese gruppen beispielsweise auf
der bühne sprechen dass es in vielen
städten unterschiedlich
in berlin gab es aber wirklich gruppen
die nicht nur keine berührungsängste mit
rechtsextremen hatten sondern und wo man
sagen muss diesen da massiv aufgetreten
und da muss man einfach eben auch
schauen als teilnehmer wie gehe ich
damit um das ist eine kritik die
geäußert wird da kann man sich
vielleicht wenn man vor ort ist mal
umschauen mit leuten reden
stimmt das stimmt das nicht und das
problem ist halt wirklich die
organisatoren müssen sich auch ihrer
verantwortung bewusst sein wenn tausende
menschen zu der veranstaltung kommen und
da kann man nicht einfach sagen sie ja
abgrenzung nach rechts brauche ich nicht
und wenn jetzt hier rechtsextreme in
großen massen mobilisieren hinzu kommen
dann habe ich damit nichts zu tun
sondern ich als veranstalter muss da
eben auch verantwortung übernehmen man
kann nämlich in deutschland auch bei
einer veranstaltung hingehen und sagen
ich hab ihr hausrecht wenn hier jemand
mit rechtsextremen symbolen rumläuft
dann kriegt er einen platzverweis und
ich habe das gefühl bei vielen der
veranstaltung hat man sich darüber
überhaupt nicht gedanken gemacht im
gegenteil der haben veranstalter gesagt
wir sind nicht rechts wir sind nicht
links
wir sind frei so und das gefällt
natürlich auch rechtsextrem und ich
finde da muss man sich auch mit der
diskussion auseinandersetzen ich finde
das ist eine durchaus berechtigte kritik
da spricht jetzt die ehemalige
politikerin aus dir habe ich ein
bisschen das gefühl wenn ich mal
zurückkommen dazu nochmal zu dem
verschwörungs die erzählung prozess am
zum ende viele menschen haben mir
geschrieben hilfe mein freund mein
bruder mein vater schickt man jetzt
solche videos wie geht man am besten mit
den leuten um denn sowas passiert
ja so am besten ist wirklich dran zu
bleiben also man sollte auf jeden fall
wenn es in einer größeren gruppe so war
beispielsweise im netz oder whatsapp
großen gruppe beispielsweise irgendwie
kita oder familie dann sollte man schon
öffentlich sagen 'du ich sehe das nicht
so oder ich finde es schwierig diese
quelle die den uci hat schon öfter
falschmeldung verbreitet wenn man so
etwas eben feststellt oder man kann auch
einen link zu einem faktencheck bringen
wenn man aber wirklich jemanden
überzeugen so dann sollte man schon ins
zwiegespräch gehen aber gibt schon gerne
öffentlich zu dass er vielleicht etwas
verbreitet hat was nicht stimmt oder
mehr bezweifelt schon gerne öffentlich
gern ja was er da gepostet hat da macht
es sinn mit jemandem zu sprechen und
fragen zu stellen so warum glaubst du
das woher hast du das glaubst du das ist
eine seriöse quelle
glaubst du dieser mensch der das sagt
ist kompetent und sich da wirklich voran
zu testen und stadt ja jemanden mit zehn
argumenten zu bombardieren reicht es
manchmal eher gezielte fragen zu stellen
oder soll ich mal ein gutes argument zu
bringen und ich denke wichtig ist auch
zu verstehen dass nicht bei allen
menschen aber einigen menschen spielt
auch die persönliche situation eine
rolle also ich hatte es angesprochen der
kontrollverlust viele menschen machen
jetzt einfach eine harte zeit durch und
viele menschen berichten eben auch dass
sie in ihrem freundeskreis im
familienumfeld leute erleben die solche
thesen oder solche erzählungen äußern
von denen sie es nie gedacht hätten und
dann hilft es manchmal vielleicht auch
einfach zu fragen so geht's dir gerade
schlecht sollen wir nicht reden und erst
mal das außen vollers natürlich bei
rassismus antisemitismus sollte man da
immer intervenieren aber vielleicht auch
gucken gibt es ein zugrunde liegendes
probieren das vielleicht sind diese
flucht und solche erzählungen auch
besonders attraktiv erscheint und wenn
die runde liegende problem angegangen
werden kann zusammen dann ist so etwas
vielleicht auch nicht mehr so attraktiv
so jetzt geht noch mal kurz durch unsere
kommentare 1 war jetzt wird uns noch mal
tatsächlich das vorgeworfen was wir
gerade angesprochen haben wir würden
einseitig berichten demos gegen
grundgesetz einschränkungen da würden
nur bekiffte schweine wirrköpfe gezeigt
oder eine der braunes gesetze von sich
gibt da sind auch heute dabei die sich
ernsthaft gedanken darum machen ich
hoffe wir haben das jetzt auch hier klar
gemacht im gespräch mit
katharina kuhn dass das manchmal
schwierig ist auseinander zu halten aber
dass es tatsächlich unterschiede gibt
die man auch ganz klar benennen kann und
benennen muss und ich hoffe wir können
uns jetzt hier in den kommentaren
einigermaßen friedlich weiter
miteinander beschäftigen auch wenn es
ein bisschen schwierig ist katharina ich
danke dir für deine zeit heute abend und
für die aufklärung und danke euch für
die aufmerksamkeit für eure fragen und
guckt nicht zu tief in den kaninchenbau
da kann man manchmal ganz schön ihre
werden in diesem sinne einen schönen
abend noch
[Musik]